ANANT AGARWAL: Welcome to MITx, MIT'S
worldwide online learning initiative.
We are delighted to have you join us for
6.002x, Circuits and Electronics,
the inaugural course of MITx.
PROFESSOR: OK, welcome to 6.002.
ANANT AGARWAL: 6.002x is the same as the
electronic circuits course taken
by MIT students as their first course
in an EE or EECS major at MIT.
This course will help you make the
transition from physics to electrical
engineering.
In this course you will learn about
a lot of fun things, including the
foundations behind many cool devices
such as the smartphone.
The course will be hard, and we
want you to stick with us.
It is our hope that you will have
a lot of fun in this course.
Let me start by introducing
you to our team.
I am Anant Agarwal.
Like most MIT faculty, I have a wide
range of interests, including a
fascination around chainsaws.
GERRY SUSSMAN: Hello, I'm Gerry Sussman,
professor of electrical
engineering at MIT.
Been a faculty member here since 1973.
I build electronics, optics, computer
software, and I repair
watches as a hobby.
PIOTR MITROS: I'm Piotr Mitros.
I'm a research scientist at MIT, and
I was in charge of developing the
software infrastructure for MITx.
As a graduate student I spent a lot of
time traveling around India, Nigeria,
and China, mostly as part of educational
technology projects.
So I'm very excited to be helping
out with this course.
ANANT AGARWAL: Whether we like chainsaws
or watches, we're all
passionate educators.
This course is free.
In this experimental first course of
MITx, the certificates are also free.
Now, this is a prototype course, and we
welcome your participation and any
feedback you might have to improving
the learning experience.
Let's get started.